>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
All of the library I want
to welcome you all here today
for this Open Mic Series.
The Open Mic Series I
actually like to think
of a tributary of the
Botkin Lectures.
It's a little bit more informal and
discussion-oriented and allows us
to have conversations with artists,
with leading scholars and researcher
who are working in
folklore, ethnomusicology,
cultural heritage studies and the
like in oral history as we're going
to find out more about today.
It is also a great strategy for
us to increase our collections
and build our collections.
This discussion today will be taped
and will become a permanent part
of our archives and we'll eventually
make its way onto our website
so that individuals around
the room; around the room,
around the world a little
bigger room [brief laughter]
and individuals in the future
will be able to listen to this.
So with that said, if you
do have any devices turned
on like cell phones and the like,
please turn it off right
now and appreciate it.
So, today we're having a
little focus on StoryCorps.
StoryCorps is a partner of
the American Folklife Center
and it was founded in 2003 by
Dave Isay and started as a booth,
recording booth in Grand Central
Station and now has turned
into this beautiful airstream
that is parked behind the Jefferson
building right now and since 2003,
or actually since 2005
when they became mobile.
They had been traveling around the
country documenting, interviewing
or allowing individuals to come
together and interview each other
and share their stories and all of
these stories are actually deposited
in the American Folklife Center.
So today, among all of
the collections we have,
today we don't really
have many interviews
with the individuals
who do the interviewing.
So today we are going to do
switch, or turn the tables here
and have an opportunity
to hear what interviewers
and what the interviewers
from StoryCorps have been doing
overall these years, roaming around
and traveling and how they
learned to do what they do
and their experiences along the way.
And I want to thank StoryCorps,
I also want to thank WAMU
who is a partner with this
residency here with StoryCorps
who will be here until
about mid-May.
They've already been here a
couple of weeks, so we're thrilled
to have them and thrilled to be a
partner and I'm going to turn this
over to Nancy Groce, American
Folklife Center a folklife
specialist who will tell
you a little bit more
about the individuals that
are going to be talking.
Thanks.
>> Nancy Groce: Great, thank you
Betsy and thank you all for coming.
So established in 2003,
StoryCorps is one
of the largest oral history
projects of its kind in the world.
In 2005, StoryCorps
converted an airstream trailer
into a traveling recording studio
which you called a mobile booth,
right, and launched its first
cross-country tour visiting cities
and towns across the
country to record stories
of the American people, partnering
with local radio stations,
cultural institutions and
community-based organizations,
StoryCorps invites pairs of
participants to spend an hour
in the mobile booth
recording their stories.
Each week millions of
people listen to excerpts
of these compelling conversations
on MPR's morning edition.
How many people here listen
to MPR's morning edition.
Ah, okay there you go and there's
also the StoryCorps Listen Page.
In recognition of its activities,
the Brooklyn-based nonprofit has
already received numerous awards
including two Peabody
Awards and in 2015,
its founder David Isay
received a TED Prize.
In 2015, it also launched the
StoryCorps Act, an innovative tool
for collecting stories that we're
going to be talking about today,
but before we get there,
I want to introduce
for four StoryCorps members,
staffers who have been
nice enough to come.
I'll start with Naomi
Blech who began work
with StoryCorps' Mobile Tour after
earning a degree in sociology
from Barnard College, and
Naomi is all the way at end.
As a facilitator, Naomi strives
according to what's on the webpage
and we always believe the
webpage, to create a space
for all individuals to
meaningfully share their stories.
She's particularly interested in the
intersection of personal narratives
and ethnographic research.
Talya Cooper is the archive
manager at StoryCorps and has been
with the organization since 2007.
She also masters in
library information sciences
from Pratt Institution
and a bachelor's degree
in anthropology from Barnard.
Felix Lopez began his
time with StoryCorps
in the Princeton Animation
Department before starting his
current role as a bilingual
mobile facilitator.
Prior to working with StoryCorps,
Felix worked in art and education,
sorry, worked in arts and education
administration; is that right?
And he earned his bachelor's degree
in Chinese language and history
from the University of Michigan.
And finally, Stacey Todd
is a native of Michigan
and claims you've sailed
extensively in great lengths,
you put that on your bio so, is that
what you wanted to be known for?
We're quoting; exactly
why we're here.
She earned her bachelor's degree in
linguistics from Brooklyn College
and she's been with StoryCorps since
2013 and you all; now let's see.
Three of you Stacey, Felix
and Naomi are facilitators
for the Mobile Booth and Talya
is here from the Brooklyn office
where you're less mobile
is that right?
>> Talya Cooper: Yes, I'm immobile,
but I work with the archive
so that's what brings me
to my connection here.
>> Stacey Todd: You're mobile today.
>> Talya Cooper: Yes.
>> Nancy Groce: So this is in some
ways sounds like a fascinating job.
So we're going to talk to you just
about what it's like to actually go
around the country and
record stories and what it's
like to also make them available
because it's not just recording
them, it's sharing them
with the people that's also
getting them on media so people sort
of value the stories and then,
of course, from the Library
of Congress' view, getting them
to the American Folklife Center
so that they can become
the permanent narrative
of our permanent collection
our permanent archive and part
of record of the American people.
So, let me start with sort
of a softball question,
actually I just went back a minute
for all of you how did you hear
about StoryCorps and did you,
were you always interested
in listening to stories?
Yeah, why don't you start?
So you've been with
StoryCorps how long Nauomi.
>> Naomi Blech: I started
as an intern this past June.
So I guess it's coming
up on a year now.
In fact, this is actually my
first stop on the mobile tour
so I've been recording with the
mobile tour for about two weeks now.
Yeah, so I'm, probably won't have
that many stories or may not be able
to answer your questions,
but I heard about StoryCorps
after graduating with a
bachelor's in sociology and sort
of being interested in
nonfiction creative storytelling
in different ways to amplify
the voices of marginalized
of disenfranchised communities
both to empower those individuals
but also to share those
narratives and make them a part
of our historical records.
>> Nancy Groce: And how did you
feel, how did you feel about?
>> Felix Lopez: So I think
I was still in education
and I was doing a lot of education
with museums and I was listening
to a lot of podcasts at this
point and I was really in-tuned
with storytelling based
on my Caribbean family.
We just over celebrations or what
not I would just tell a story
and with descriptions and it's
this art of really celebrating life
and I really got in-tuned with
not just history but oral history
when I got into Chinese language
and culture and how in-tune
that culture is to storytelling
with its long history and I wanted
to get involved with
the organization
that not only tells the history,
but kind of changes the narrative
and gives it back to the
people and gives them ownership
of what they want to say
and how they want to say it.
And that's when I got
into StoryCorps and I saw,
and I've been with this past June
so it's almost coming up to a year
and seeing the different facets
of what StoryCorps does not just
seeing it in a broadcast light,
but all the different perspectives
and missions that StoryCorps does
to amplify the voices
of everyday Americans.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, how about you?
>> Stacey Todd: Sure.
Let's see, I've always
been a people person.
I've always been very curious,
ask a lot of questions.
I had a nonlinear path to school,
so was in the service industry
for ten years, so I'm a big
customer service person.
I ended up working at
StoryCorps for two years
in the Public Information
and Services Department.
So I was the person that people
went to when they had questions,
which people have a lot of
questions about StoryCorps.
So I worked very closely with Talya
in the Recording Archives
Department,
the Education Department, you
know, all of our different booths
across the country
fielding questions,
sending organization towards them.
But then in January of this year,
I started as the manager
of the Mobile Booth.
But yeah, I studied
linguistics at Brooklyn College
and that did not lead me
necessarily to StoryCorps.
I needed an internship in
my last semester of school
so I was an interest StoryCorps.
>> Nancy Groce: Which
is in Brooklyn.
It's in downtown Brooklyn, right?
>> Stacey Todd: Yes.
Yes in Fort Greene.
It's a fantastic place
to be an intern.
They're very in demand
these internships.
A very large number of StoryCorps
staff members were interns.
Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: They
just [inaudible]
through the organization?
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah.
It's a six month, five
day a week commitment
at with StoryCorps
internship typically.
So, yeah, I think Talya
were not an intern right?
The three of us that are on
the Mobile Tour were interns.
Yeah mine was from June
to December of 2013, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: And Talya
you, how did you get
to connected with StoryCorps?
>> Talya Cooper: Well, I've
been with the organization
for eight-and-a-half years, so it's
a little bit fuzzy to remember.
But.
>> Stacey Todd: How many people
worked with StoryCorps in 2007?
>> Talya Cooper: Probably less than
half the number of people that.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, how many
people work for StoryCorps now?
>> Talya Cooper:
About a hundred-forty people
work at the organization.
We have locations across,
so in addition
to the Mobile Tour we
have our office New York.
We also have permanent recording
locations in Chicago, Atlanta
and San Francisco and staff
at all of those sites as well.
Yeah, I came to StoryCorps kind
of from a three pronged interest
in being archivist and coming to
work with a really cool collection.
I've also worked in, I'd worked
in radio and audio and music stuff
so I was just really interested
in sound and sound reporting
and then I also came from a
background in social sciences
and ethnography and kind of the
minutia of everyday life and getting
to be a part of kind of bearing
witness to that and preserving
that is something that's always
been really appealing to me.
>> Nancy Groce: So can one of you
walk us or some of you walk us
through what happens in
a StoryCorps interview?
How do people sign up?
How do you get people to come
there and then how do you walk them
through what they're going to do,
because one of the interesting
things for me as a folklorist is
that your model is not
to have someone who's a professional
interviewer do it right?
It's to have people who
know each other and most
of whom are not done
this very thing before?
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah, we
prefer it it's not scripted.
We prefer if it's not interviewers,
because that's not the StoryCorps,
StoryCorps is a forty minute
conversation uninterrupted
with somebody that you know.
But I'll start with a process
people make a reservation
for an appointment.
I'm sorry to tell you that all
of our appointments are booked
for Washington, D.C. You can get
on our waitlist if you'd like to be
on the waitlist if you're going to
be in D.C. for you know the rest
of our time here, we'd be happy
to have you on our waiting list.
But you need an appointment, so
the way the Mobile Tour works,
a couple of weeks before we get
to town our appointments go live
on our website and people
can make an appointment.
It's a free public service.
So you sign up for an appointment,
you need to have a partner
and then one our staff members
from our office will call you
and make sure that you
understand what you signed up for
and that you have a general idea
of what you're going to talk about.
We prefer that you don't know
exactly what you're going
to talk about, but you
have a general idea.
So you have a date and a
time for your appointment
and then you [multiple
speakers], exactly.
The appointment takes about an
hour, but you have forty minutes
of uninterrupted recording time.
So you show up, we ask that you show
up ten or fifteen minutes early,
you fill out a datasheet which
is just how we build a profile
of our participants in the archive.
Why don't, do you want to take it
from there Felix what happens after?
>> Felix Lopez: Sure.
Once participants come
in, we tell them to come
in about ten minutes before
their appointment time
and a facilitator either me or Naomi
will come in, will come outside
and introduce ourselves and they'll
fill out a participant datasheet
which is just to build a
profile for StoryCorps.
But usually what we tell them is
what's the most important part
about the datasheet, because
there are some questions
that for some people
may be very particular
and they might be a
little uncomfortable,
is that all those questions
that they fill out are optional.
They can fill out as much or
as little as they like and so
after they fill out the participant
datasheet they come into the booth
and it's always interesting
seeing their different reactions
to the booth; oh it's quaint or
it's cozy or do you live here?
>> Stacey Todd: Or it's
bigger than I expected.
>> Felix Lopez: Or it's bigger
than I expected and from there
on out we situate them and make them
feel as comfortable as possible.
When we get into the recording
part, because there's two rooms
within the airstream
trailer; there's one where we
and the facilitators database
and the other room is
the recording studio
and then we really start
talking to them a little bit
about what the process looks like.
Within that sixty minute
appointment, forty minutes is
of uninterrupted conversation time
and the facilitator is
we're only there just really
to make sure the sound
quality is okay.
We're going to be jotting
down notes,
summarizing the conversation every
few minutes or so and then also
like we may have some questions
sometimes, but really it is the time
for participants that are there to
really talk about whatever they want
and participants talk from love
to someone in the their family
that just passed, recent proposals.
>> Naomi Blech: I had a proposal
in the booth, yeah, a few days ago.
>> Felix Lopez: So, do you want to?
>> Did she say yes?
>> Naomi Blech: She did say yes.
>> Felix Lopez: Do you want
to continue from there?
>> Naomi Blech: Yeah, sure.
I'd like to say that I may
ask some clarifying questions
like if they bring up Bob
and they've never brought
him up before just
for archival purposes,
I would say who's that?
Or to invite participants to explore
an area or a topic a little bit more
and in that case it's obviously
always optional, you know,
it's an appointment
between the two of them
to archive their stories together
so they can always skip that,
but I think that you can
sort of tell if they're going
to be receptive to a question
like that and it's often something
that can enrich the experience.
So I feel very privileged to be able
to ask those questions every once
in a while and sort of spark
something in the conversation
that might have gone
overlooked, so I think that's one
of the coolest parts of the job.
And then at the ends we
stop their recording,
we give them you know ten minute,
five minute, one minute hand signals
and then we give them a CD of their
recording to take home that day
which is really neat and we
invite them to archive their story
with StoryCorps and at
the Library of Congress.
It's definitely very optional.
The release forms range from walking
away with the only copy of the CD
to archiving at the
Library of Congress some
of our partner archives at that the
Smithsonian, or to just archiving
at the Library of Congress and
not giving StoryCorps access
to your content, to produce for
radio potential which is only less
than one percent of that stories.
But or to use for educational or
promotional purposes and things
like that, but a lot of people
are really excited by sort
of how easily they able
to open up or what came
out in those forty minutes
and are excited to archive it,
so that's also something
that's really neat.
And then we take some photos for
the archive, some group photos
and some individual photos and we
give individuals the opportunity
to make a small donation to
StoryCorps and that's about it.
>> Stacey Todd: I was just
going to say that the,
we refer to the recording
space as a sacred space
and people are often surprised
by how quickly they are able
to make themselves
vulnerable or share something
that they've never shared before
or how easy it is to ask a question
of somebody who, you know, you've
never asked that question before.
>> Nancy Groce: Is that
because of the physical space
or is it the event that they've
signed up for and they've agreed to?
>> Stacey Todd: It's a
combination of all of that.
I definitely think the
physical space helps.
It's very dim inside the booth, just
two lights over the participants;
the light near the facilitator
is usually turned off.
It's pretty cozy.
The booth seats are really worn in.
The way it's setup is like a booth
at a diner, yet we need new cushions
which we're getting, but you
know we have limited resources.
So if our booth seats are a little
squishy that's why, but no I think
that is, think of we've; the Mobile
Tour has been traveling the country
since 2005 nonstop.
So, think of all the thousands of
people who have sat in that space
and had a moment, had
shared something you know.
There are lots of tears.
People always say that the
cry during our broadcast,
well there's a lot of
crying in the booth,
but it's happy tears
sometimes, of course,
like people share traumatic things.
It's just, you can, the space has
an energy to it and I do think
that the space contributes to
the quality of the conversation.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, can you guess
what people are going to talk
about by as they come, by the
way they carry themselves,
the way they look?
>> Naomi Blech: No.
>> Felix Lopez: Definitely not.
Definitely not.
>> Nancy Groce: Give me an example.
>> Felix Lopez: I think I
can like even give an example
from something that
happened yesterday.
Someone from our outreach
organization came in and it was her
and her husband and they were very,
I mean they were giddy and happy
and excited, but I think you can't
really assume; one of the things
about being a facilitator is
that you really can't assume what
people are going to come in with
or what they're going to say or what
the conversation is going to be like
and so it's kind of like just when
you're meeting a new person, for me,
I feel like when people tell their
stories it's always a present
for me, because I'm humble in
space where I'm part of your life
for forty minutes and I'm
hearing things that not a lot
of people can hear or
will hear in their lives.
And especially with
two people that are
so personally connected I think life
is life and that we have errands
to run and we have things to
do that we never have the space
to have those conversations
or we really avoid those
conversations sometimes.
And so with the space, that sacred
space that they mentioned there is
that time where people are
like asking those questions
and there's nowhere to go, it's
like you're going to
say, you're going to.
>> Stacey Todd: People
can leave if they want.
>> Felix Lopez: They can leave, but.
>> Stacey Todd: That's one thing
we tell people is you have forty
minutes and people usually use it
all and it usually goes really fast,
but you don't have to use it all.
If at any moment you feel
like you're finished,
you can give us a signal
and we stop the recording.
>> Felix Lopez: But it's like
not like, oh you, but like I feel
like when it comes to a
very personal conversation,
when someone asks a question
you feel like this is the time
where I'm archiving this and this
is the only time I'm going to talk
about this, why don't
I answer it now?
And so when that couple came
in, they just started talking
about their grandma, the woman
started talking about her grandma
and by the second or third
question about talking
about her favorite memories
with her grandma in Ukraine,
she started crying and talking
about being a Ukrainian woman
in the United States and
traveling at immigration
and I couldn't assume all that
stuff just by seeing her ill
out a participant datasheet
or saying hello.
So there's always those little
boughs of surprises that come
when you're a facilitator.
>> Nancy Groce: You mentioned
outreach organizations.
Can you talk a little bit
about that, because maybe a lot
of people don't realize
how much thought goes
into who you're interviewing?
>>
>> Naomi Blech: Yeah, so
a few months before we,
before I scheduled stuff, we
start in the office doing outreach
on organizations that are
working with populations
that are underrepresented in
the media or in our archives.
We have different initiatives
for LGBTQ communities,
for Latino voices,
for African-American
and Black stories for;
am I forgetting any?
>> Felix Lopez: Military voices.
>> Naomi Blech: Military voices.
We try to, we try go
special initiatives
to incorporate voices
that we are noticing.
We notice that we're
represent we're in need of,
but besides that so we'll do
research on the upcoming stop.
We'll look at the demographics
of the stop and we'll reach
out to nonprofits, you know,
community-based organizations,
just individuals who we think have a
lot of connections in the community
and we'll invite them to a community
partnership meeting which happens
about a month before the stop
where one of our colleagues
from the office travels
to the location and meets
with potential point people
from those organizations
to tell them what a StoryCorps
partnership looks like.
And then if they decide that
they want to be partners
with us they'll get access
to a private calendar
where they can reach out to people
within their networks and sign them
up for appointments, so about
half of our appointments and more
than half in Washington, D.C. go to
people who wouldn't have been able
to sign up, or wouldn't have
known to sign up for appointments
without this extra element
of outreach which is one
of the main focuses
in the office one
of the really cool
things about StoryCorps.
>> Stacey Todd: Naomi and Felix
both spend about twenty-five percent
of their time in the office in
Brooklyn, so we have a team,
the Mobile Team has
three facilitators,
Vera is not here today, but
she's in the office in Brooklyn
so they rotate through
and they work mainly
in the office in Brooklyn
as outreach.
We take it very seriously.
>> Nancy Groce: And how long
are you, I know you're here
for five weeks I believe.
Is that a standard length
of time to be at a site?
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah.
>> Felix Lopez: Yes.
>> Stacey Todd: Four to
five weeks in each city.
>> Nancy Groce: And then you
operate eight hours a day,
you do eight interviews a day?
>> Stacey Todd: Seven.
>> Nancy Groce: Seven interviews
and lunch [multiple speakers].
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah, exact yeah.
It's a long day especially you
know in D.C. now we're commuting
on the train just like we do in New
York, so we leave about 9 O'clock
in the morning and our last
appointment finishes at 6:30 so we,
and then we have databasing
to do at the end of the day.
So we don't leave the booth
until about 7 or 7:30.
>> Nancy Groce: And it's all
very intense work, right?
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah.When people are
in there you really
have to pay attention.
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: So what do
you do on your time off?
You're all, you traveling
the country.
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah.
>> Naomi Blech: As a
group and that must be.
>> Stacey Todd: It's interesting.
There's some days and each city
also has a different feel to it.
It feels like there's so
much to do in Washington,
D.C. that I don't want to just
like lay around the house.
So I've been going to
museums and going for walks
and you know the weather's
been be beautiful.
But there are days
when, because it is
such an emotionally tiring job some
days, that you just want to like lay
on the couch and watch Netflix.
So it's a variation of different
things and every city that we're
in our living situation is
different, so we're in partnership
with the local public radio station
and WAMU has found
us a fantastic house.
We feel very fancy.
We have a backyard and a porch and
a front swing on the front porch.
>> Nancy Groce: We can come visit.
We can do some.
>> Stacey Todd: It's
really-really nice,
so but it's not always like that.
Felix and I in Las Cruces,
New Mexico this January lived
for a month in a pretty like
mediocre hotel and I ate
so many frozen burritos
in New Mexico,
so I'm happy that we have a full
kitchen and a beautiful house now.
>> Naomi Blech: I'm getting spoiled.
That's true.
>> Felix Lopez: And then in San
Antonio we had our own apartment.
So in addition to going
to different cities,
the living situation can be very
different also whether that be
like with the distance to the booth.
For like in San Antonio we walked
five minutes away from the booth.
In Las Cruces we drove for
like fifteen minutes here,
it's like an hour commute but
it is the metro so it's nice
because there are some, there is
some pros of being in the metro.
You can, after the booth we're
already in the hills so we can
like go out or go to dinner.
>> Stacey Todd: We don't have to
drive here which is fantastic.
Felix and Naomi are both native
New Yorkers and we're a team
that travels the country
with two vehicles.
So it makes, I'm a Midwesterner
so I, but driving is no big deal
for me, but these two it
makes me a little nervous,
so I'm grateful [brief laughter].
I'm grateful when they
don't have to drive.
>> Felix Lopez: She's right.
>> Stacey Todd: We,
I should say anymore.
>> Nancy Groce: So now one
of the ways most people
hear StoryCorps I think is
on MPR and Friday mornings.
How many people again here listen
to this on a regular basis?
So a lot of people.
Can you talk to us
about the relationship
of what you're recording?
How do you select those vignettes
because I assume they're edited?
And so do you, when you're
sitting there listening
through all these stories do you,
when you hear a really great
story do you sort of mark it or,
how do you filter things?
>> Stacey Todd: Well we have a
production department that goes
through the archive and
finds what they're looking
for for that particular day.
Talya, do you want to
talk about this at all?
>> Talya Cooper: Sure, yeah.
So I think Naomi, I
think we have a total
of about six-hundred produced pieces
that have been generated for MPR
and our archive has sixty-six
thousand interviews in it.
The broadcast pieces are
about two-and-a-half minutes
on the interviews themselves
or forty minutes.
So as you can tell it's a very-very
small percentage of our archive
that currently is made
available to the public to hear
which is something
that we in the archive
at StoryCorps are working very
difficult, working very hard
to change with the
generous partnership
of the American Folklife
Center which is the only place
that you can currently go to and
listen to interviews in full.
So the way, the production
department has a few
different priorities.
We want to, in producing
pieces we want
to represent diverse populations
and also diverse kinds of pairings
of people, so not have every
single broadcast that goes
on MPR be a grandfather, you know,
giving sound advice to his grandson,
like trying to have different
dimensions, different kinds
of relationships and different kinds
of stories and we also do some work,
or the production department
rather which is not my area
of expertise try and often find
kind of untold stories or kind
of lesser known historical
events that might relate
to something that's in the news.
So I remember we did a piece on
Orangeburg where there is a bunch
of people killed in a Civil
Rights protest in South Carolina.
>> Nancy Groce: Orangeburg where?
>> Talya Cooper: South Carolina.
>> Nancy Groce: South
Carolina, okay.
>> Talya Cooper: And that
was something that, you know,
is not a story that a lot of people
know about that is related to a lot
of kind of better known
historical events.
So that's something that we do,
or that our production
department does rather,
but then when these folks
are listening to interviews
in the booth there is kind
of different standards,
or not standards but
just different things
that they're keeping their
ear out for which is kind of,
not just interesting content, but
well-told stories you know people
who have particularly
compelling voices or something.
And it, you know, we
never want to say
that you know a certain story
is better than another story
because especially from an archival
perspective like even a kind
of dryly told story
has valuable kind
of evidentiary information
things like that.
BF that's kind of the, I don't know.
>> Stacey Todd: I do have a couple
of our broadcasts that were recorded
on the Mobile Tour setup
if you want to play one.
And if anybody's interested
in hearing the story
we'd be happy to do that.
It looks like I see some nods.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, yeah.
Let's get a sample.
>> Stacey Todd: Pardon me.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
>> Stacey Todd: I should be able
to do it from here, let me see.
Here we go.
So this was recorded in
Jackson, Mississippi.
Our Mobile Tour was
there in 2015 I believe.
This is a father and son
pairing, Albert and Ayden Sykes.
This is one of my favorites.
>> Do you remember what was going
through your head when
you first saw me?
>> I remember when the
doctor pulled you out.
The first thing I thought was that
he was being too rough with you
and he actually held you
like a little Sprite bottle
and he was like "Here's your baby."
That was the most proud
moment of my life.
Don't tell your brothers,
because there's three of you all,
but it was like looking
at a blank canvas
and just imagining what you want
the painting to look like at the end
but also knowing you can't
control the paint strokes.
You know, the fear was just, I got
to bring up Black boy in Mississippi
which is a tough place
to bring up kids period,
but there are statistics
that say Black boys born
after the year 2002 have a one in
three chance of going to prison.
And all three of my sons were
born after the year 2002.
>> So dad, why do you take
me to protests so much?
>> I think I take you
for a bunch of reasons.
One is that I want you
to see what it looks
like when people come together,
but also that you understand
that it is not just about
people that are familiar to you,
but it's about everybody.
Did you know the work that
Martin Luther King was doing was
for everybody and it wasn't
just for Black people?
>> Yes, I understand that.
>> Yeah, so that's
how you got to think.
You decide that you
want to be a cab driver,
then you got to be the
most impactful cab driver
that you can possibly be.
>> Are you proud of me?
>> Of course.
You're my man.
I just love everything
about you period.
>> The thing I love the about
you, you never give up on me.
That's one of the things I will
always remember about my dad.
>> Wow, you said it like
I'm on the way out of here
or like I'm already gone.
>> So dad, what are
your dreams for me?
>> My dream is for you
to live out your dreams.
There's an old proverb that talks
about when children are
born the children come
out with their fists closed because
that's where they keep their gifts
and as you grow your hands learn
to unfold because you're learning
to release your gift to the
world and so for the rest
of your life I want to see you
live with your hands unfolded.
[ Music ]
>> Stacey Todd: I think
that's a good example
of one that's obviously compelling
but the dynamic between the two
of them is really what the story is.
The relationship is the story.
>> Nancy Groce: And that
was a straight conversation.
You didn't redo, sometimes
take a longer conversation
and edited it down
>> Stacey Todd: Oh,
that was highly edited.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> Stacey Todd: I mean, that.
>> Nancy Groce: That
was highly edited?
>> Stacey Todd: That hours and
hours and hours of editing.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh.
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah,
that was a four,
at least a forty minute
conversation to begin with.
I know it sounds like, it sounds
like they were just talking
naturally, but that's the magic
of the StoryCorps editing.
The production team, I mean,
endless hours of editing.
Not to say that the conversation,
I'm sure like if you listen
to the full interview it
would probably entertain us
and like touch us the whole way
through, that's what I imagine,
but we couldn't play a forty minute
conversation on morning edition.
>> Nancy Groce: So
you distill it down.
>> Stacey Todd: Exactly.
Yeah, I wish there was some,
none of us are directly
in the production department.
Naomi and Felix when they're in the
office they do first cuts on pieces
that they are assigned to.
That's another one of their
duties when they're in the office.
So they can speak a bit
more about that possibly,
but we don't have a representative
from our production
department here unfortunately.
Do you want to say anything about
your experience in production Felix?
>> Felix Lopez: Production
is really fun.
But, yeah, so we basically
get assigned once a week
to edit a first cut.
So sometimes production
interviews can be forty minutes
or sometimes it can be longer,
sixty minutes, seventy-five minutes
and the first cut is basically
listening to the story
and really seeing like what kind
of theme do you really hear the
story that's the most compelling
or like whether you, what sparks
at you or kind of; whatever emotion
that you're feeling from
that first listening.
And then you edit it to a theme
and then with the producer
that is helping you with the edit
for that shift will
pretty much listen to it
and just have some suggestions and
if it gets green lit then it goes
into the production meeting where
they talk about it even further
about whether they should keep on
editing it or cutting it, so forth.
>> Nancy Groce: Interesting.
Now I want to highlight
the Mobile Booth
as well as we have you all here.
Since Talya is here, I wondered
if you can say a few words
about StoryCorps Me and the app?
>> Talya Cooper: Sure.
So that's a big, has been kind of
a see change at the organization.
We created a mobile recording
app kind of as the result of TEDs
of Dave rather, Dave the founder
of StoryCorps winning the TED Prize
and it's available for all
manner of mobile device.
You can go to the app
store and download it.
And basically it, I think the
original idea was to have it be kind
of a "additional facilitator" not
that anything could ever replace the
work that these magical people do,
but it has a built-in recorder
and question generator.
So, if you're somewhere where
you're unavailable to come to record
with StoryCorps, if you have
a really great conversation
at StoryCorps and want to
keep talking to other folks
in your family, all
these other things,
you can just you know use your
mobile phone, record on it
and then it is uploaded kind of
via SoundCloud and sent directly
to the collection at the AFC.
>> Nancy Groce: To the
archive here right?
>> Talya Cooper: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: And a lot of
people are using this right?
>> Talya Cooper: Yeah.
A little bird told me that there
were eight-three thousand interviews
on the site as this morning.
They are very different
from the interviews
that we record actually
through the booth.
They tend to be quite short often.
One thing that's really
great, you saw like a second
of the booth in the video.
The sound quality is wonderful.
They're like very, the booths
that we have are really
nicely soundproofed.
We have really good equipment.
They sound really good.
And just the fact that you're not
sitting around in your living room
or your high school cafeteria
or wherever it is kind
of gives a gravity to the interview
that doesn't necessarily come
with the interviews on the app, so
there are, I mean which isn't to say
that they aren't also
important or meaningful
or any number of other things.
They just tend to be
shorter and a bit different,
but they're also all accessible to
be listened to at StoryCorps.me.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay and so people
can visit them through your website?
>> Talya Cooper: Yeah.
Through the story, which
is through StoryCorps.me.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
And at this point maybe we can take
a few questions from the audience.
What are people curious about?
>> And we have a mic.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh yes, I'm
sorry we have a roaming mic.
Oh, we'll start, we'll
get to you in a minute.
Yeah go ahead.
>> I wondered what kind of
guidance you give the interviewers
at the beginning of their session
with regard to you know kinds
of questions to ask or ways to sort
of ask follow-up questions
things like that.
>> Stacey Todd: A lot of the
preparation takes place weeks
in advance when our team calls you.
If you have an appointment
you get a phone call
and we always ask do
you have an idea
of what you're going talk about,
and then we do have a
list of great questions.
They're called StoryCorps' great
questions, so they're types
of things like how would
like to be remembered
or has been the kindest
to you in your life?
So people aren't required
to use these questions
but they're really good suggestive
questions as conversation starters.
But once you're in the booth, we
usually tell people to it's great
to have questions in front of
you as an idea, but you know what
like toss them out the window
if your partner says something
that interests you and follow-up.
I think the most important
thing is to listen
to what they're saying
and to follow-up.
Sometimes we get, fairly regularly
on the Mobil Tour we
have young folks coming
in interviewing their grandparents
so it's like a twelve-year-old
and a lot of times they get
really stuck on their questions
and they think like, oh grandma just
said something really interesting
but I have to ask this
question next,
so it's kind of the same
recommendation for anybody
like follow-up with
something that interests you.
Don't get too set on asking
the next question on your list.
>> Nancy Groce: I think
there's a question right there.
>> I interviewed when StoryCorps was
on the Madison a number of years ago
and we were a little bit nervous.
I was telling stories
about the library.
And so we wore our oldest clothes
and when we had our pictures taken
and then several years later I
found myself up on the web even
in this disastrous looking
shirt and I didn't know
if you regularly put them up or
if it was because I saw on a blog,
StoryCorps blog Connie Carter
said she was coming back
after fifty years at the Library
of Congress, but guess what?
She was back in fifteen
minutes with chocolate cookies
because her mother went
to school with the mother
of the chocolate chip cookie and so
I don't know if it was associated
with the blog or do you
naturally have people's pictures
up on the web.
>> Stacey Todd: I'm not sure
exactly where you saw your photo
and I apologize if
that was a surprise.
I know it used to be commonplace
that we were just really
excited about our participants.
We used to post all of
our participant photos
on the Mobile Tour on
like a Flicker page,
but we have stopped doing that.
But it's also possible that it
was, there was StoryCorps blog
and you may have been featured
on the StoryCorps blog,
so that's possible.
It's not.
>> Yeah. It's not usual.
>> Stacey Todd: No it's not usual,
but if you do; so the release form
that you signed if you want to give
a copy to the Library of Congress
and to StoryCorps it's called
our general release form,
and if you sign the general
release form it does mean
that we are able to
post your photo, so.
>> Oh I'm sure I did sign the.
>> Stacey Todd: But, again,
it would hard for me to say
if I don't exactly where you
saw your photo, but I'm sorry.
>> No, no.
Yeah.
>> Stacey Todd: We tend
to tell people now,
like your photo will be
taken so wear whatever you'd
like your photo to be taken in.
>> Yeah.
>> Stacey Todd: A lot of times
people are like, oh I didn't know
that you were going
to take my picture.
>> Thanks.
>> The question I have
is for the collections.
If you wanted to go to the
American Folklife Center and you,
do have to remember the name of
that particular child and his father
or can you just say I want something
on family relationships
in the South?
What, are you using
cross-indexing through the Library
of Congress or what are you doing?
>> Nancy Groce: Yes, yes.
We can cross-index them and
some of our archivists are here
and I can turn it over to them for
better explanations, but do you want
to talk a little bit about
how things are indexed?
>> Talya Cooper: Sure, yeah.
Every interview has and actually
Naomi and Felix can speak
to this too because they do a lot
of our kind of on the fly archiving,
but every interview is archived with
a description, a kind of summary
of the handwritten
notes that they take
that are timecoded throughout
the course of the interview
and we have a set of
key words as well.
Those fixed vocabulary are
kind of like optional kind
of whatever terms seem applicable
that these folks can apply and then
when we're searching the collection
we have a lot of kind of versatility
and you know different kinds of ways
that we can cross-index
things or things like that.
The collection as I
mentioned, is very-very large,
so if you were you know to come in
and look for the Sykes interview
and know only that it was about
you know a family in the South,
it would probably take
a bit of digging.
But thankfully like
obviously the staff
at the AFC is extremely
familiar with what we have.
Do you all want to
say more about that?
>> Felix Lopez: Yeah.
So some of the things that we do
at the end of the interview too is
if they mentioned someone
often throughout the interview,
we tell them to write the name down
so they can be part of the keywords.
Some of our keywords are
also places, famous people
and then we do also have
like a set of keywords
that are already prefixed
in when we're databasing
and there are things
like holidays or health,
etcetera so if you have some general
idea you can put that in and then
from there you might have
another idea like, oh maybe I want
to learn a little bit more about
Vietnam and then from Vietnam oh
but maybe I want to learn
also about Vietnam and home.
And then you can you
write home and just
from there it gets more specific
to what interviews are out there.
>> Nancy Groce: Carl had a question.
>> One of the appealing things
about the Friday morning broadcast
is you do get these little gems each
one individual, but I
wondered especially now
that I've learned how carefully the
collection as a whole is structured
through these outreach
activities and looking
for underrepresented classes as to
whether yet scholars have come along
to try to get at generalizations
or finding shall we say
that represent groups or
classes of interviews rather
than these little individual gems.
>> Talya Cooper: Yeah.
I can, I mean, I can
answer a little bit just
about what researchers have been
doing with the collection so far.
Actually a lot of their
research interest
in the collection is linguistic,
people who are more interested in it
as a just a tremendous kind
of mind of people talking.
So people who want to do kind
of natural language processing
that kind of thing are really-really
interested in working with it.
And there have been, and I
mean people kind of take,
tend to take cross-sections
of it rather than looking
at it overarching so we've had a
lot of people; we have a partnership
with the National September 11th
Memorial Museum and we've had a lot
of folks to come in to look at
kind of how people talk about 9-11
and the conventions and story court
interviews versus and other kinds
of oral histories or
oral narratives.
So that's the kind of stuff
that people have been doing,
but at this point it's so large that
no one has really come in to kind
of be like this is the
nature of what is being done
in a story court interview that
isn't represented elsewhere.
>> Stacey Todd: I remember
when I was working
in the office there was a fantastic
presentation from a researcher
from Harvard who, she spent,
I think for two years she studied
only twenty-two interviews.
They were all from teachers
talking to teachers and she wanted
to know specifically about that
relationship of how do teachers talk
to each other about teaching.
But she spent two years because each
of the twenty-two interviews
was about forty minutes.
She transcribed each of those
conversations word for word
and if you're talking
about transcribing a forty minute
interview that's pages and pages.
>> Nancy Groce: Lots
and lots of work.
>> Stacey Todd: It's a lot of text.
So, yeah that's I mean
I just remember that.
It stuck out in my mind,
just like a tiny bit
of our archive creates
a ton of data.
>> Naomi Blech: And also I
think the initiatives sort
of have larger groupings of stories
in that way, so you know the ones
that are broadcast
through storious [phonetic]
or different initiatives
might be those little gems
that you're talking about, but we
also checkoff in our archiving work
if an interview qualifies for
one of those initiatives and then
if it gets, you were
looking for larger groupings
of stories you can just look
at the entire initiative.
>> Felix Lopez: Oh, and just to
clarify, storiouses are initiative
where we collect and archive
stories on Latinos or Latinas
or Hispanics all across
America and in addition,
archiving in the Library
of Congress.
We archive these stories
into the University
of Texas Benson Collection.
>> Nancy Groce: Do you want say a
few words about upcoming initiatives
because you're doing some
very interesting work
in the future we've been
concentrating on today
and yesterday, but what's
coming up for StoryCorps?
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah,
we have a new project
that just launched called the
StoryCorps Justice Project
and we are, well our next stop
after Washington, D.C. is Baltimore
and as the Mobile Tour we
are doing our first work
with the Justice Project
in Baltimore
and I'm shouldn't say too
much because I don't know,
maybe Talya do you have the language
to describe what we're doing?
We're working, as far as
I understand we're working
to record the stories of folks
who are previously incarcerated.
Do you have anything
you'd like to add?
>> Talya Cooper: Yeah.
It's specifically focused on
jails and kind of jails as opposed
to prisons and the roles that
those play in communities and kind
of general and the larger structure
of mass incarceration
in this country.
It's explicitly an advocacy project
which is a little bit
different for us.
But it is going to be, we're
really excited about it and I think
that it's going to yield some
really tremendous stories.
We have another initiative that
we haven't mentioned so far
which is our legacy initiative which
works with folks who are dealing
with life-threatening illnesses
and other kinds of conditions.
It does a lot of work
with hospice organizations
and those interviews are a little
bit different from the ones
that record in the mobile booth
because what we actually
do is train staff
at those different organizations
to go out and record interviews
like in people's homes because
mostly, because many of the folks
who are eligible to participate in
Legacy are not necessarily mobile
or able to come to the booth.
So this kind of empowers the
people who are going to be working
with them to go out and
record interviews with them
and it's a really great
project and we've recorded a lot
of really-really fascinating
content through that.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh yes.
>> So I'm wondering you know
everybody has these life stories
of people that their family's with
and maybe they don't have a chance
to get to be in the mobile
booth but they want to be able
to record those life stories
and do what you guys kind of do.
Do you guys have any, other than
the app is there any program to sort
of empower people to make their own
oral history within their family?
>> Nancy Groce: This StoryCorps Me?
>> Oh, other than the app yeah.
>> Stacey Todd: Yeah the
app in StoryCorps Me;
StoryCorps Me is just the
online platform for the app,
but really the bottom line is and
I hope that that's the message
that StoryCorps has spread
is that it's important
to record conversations
of those that you love
and that people who
are closest to you.
So the bottom line is record the
story, like I besides doing the work
that we're doing and putting
the app out into the world,
there isn't a push to
spread oral history.
But I do hope that
people are inspired
when they hear the Friday
morning broadcast to sit down
and record a conversation.
You don't have to be at one of our
recording booths, you don't have
to use our app to preserve
a story of a loved one.
>> But for years you've been
have you not been situated
outside prisons?
I mean was it, I thought, you
know sometimes libraries, banks,
prisons I thought that you had done
prisons right from the beginning?
>> Stacey Todd: We
recorded a few at prisons,
but I think it's really there's a
lot of logistical issues that come
up when we've tried to
partner with prisons and jails.
It's not an easy thing to do.
There's a lot of legal
ramifications.
So no, I know of one broadcast
in particular that was recorded
at a facility outside of Chicago.
But from my knowledge, we haven't
done a lot of recording at prisons.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, yes.
>> Just quickly your favorite
story and who would you interview?
>> Stacey Todd: Well
that's easy for me.
I'll go first.
I've already interviewed
both my mother and my father.
I would love to interview
my brother.
That hasn't happened
yet, but it will happen
within the next year I'm sure.
My favorite story that
I've recorded?
I mean there's so many to choose
from, but one that will always stick
in my mind and I don't remember
if Felix was with my that day.
In Las Cruces, New Mexico
I recorded a conversation
with two street musicians like
elderly just like amazing people
in Las Cruces, like very
well-known in the community
and it was just fantastic to
hear them talk to each other,
but also like the brought in
their guitars and played music.
I, people play music fairly
regularly in the booth.
It's not something that we
necessarily tell them to bring
in their instruments, but before we
came to D.C. we were in Nashville
and there was a lot
of music in the booth.
A woman wore a washboard tie one day
to the booth and played and sang.
That was one of, that was one of
favorite things is when people sing
in the booth, so those
stick out in my memory.
Felix.
>> Felix Lopez: Since you're like
talking about musical instruments,
two of my favorite things like
when I interview is like one is
when it involves children
because they sometimes,
they surprise me every time
whether they're interviewing
or whether they be the storyteller.
And there's this one child in
particular, I think this is
in San Antonio and he
specifically plays the accordion,
he is eight years old
and he plays this type
of music called [foreign
word spoken].
And it's a very old, it's an
old theme of music usually
of in the Mexican community and
he's the youngest person who plays
in the band that is learning
[foreign word spoken]
and learning accordion.
I think the next, the next
youngest is like in their sixties.
So like he is like
the, very-very young
and he just played the whole time.
He barely said a word or
two, he's like can I play?
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
And he's like can I
play another song?
Can I play another, so basically the
whole interview was him playing the
accordion and it just showed
he's like one of the things
that he learned was you have
to practice every day
or else I won't be good.
And like having that value
already like in his mind and seeing
like what the potential is for him
in the future was just a
wonderful interview, so.
>> Stacey Todd: Who
would you interview?
>> Felix Lopez: Who
would I interview?
I, I think I would interview, I
haven't interviewed my mom yet,
so that would be interesting.
>> Nancy Groce: And Naomi?
>> Naomi Blech: I don't have
a favorite, but one that stuck
out to me from this
trip was this woman
who is doing genealogy
research on her family and sort
of was not reunited,
because they'd only heard
about each other a little
bit through childhood.
They never actually met
with her cousin who was one
of the first famous classical
African-American concert pianists
and had like traveled the
world and did all these things
and she was able to, you
know, meet back up with him
and he was a really big influence in
her son's life now and it was just
like a whole full circle type of
interview that was really touching
and then I did a little bit
of research about him after,
it was just really impressive
and I was really excited,
but I also love when kids come in.
And I would interview
a family member,
there's so many people
I want to hear about,
my mom, my brother, I guess.
>> Stacey Todd: I think Talya
you can answer this question too,
what's your favorite
story in the archives?
>> Talya Cooper: There's so-so
many, but there's one that I always,
that I just always think of
whenever someone asks me what
about my favorite interview is.
So it's just like kind of like
related to people being unexpected,
it came in through
one of our actually
through Legacy initiative you know
and there's a picture of this kind
of mild-mannered looking
old lady and she talks
about being a Nascar driver.
Like a stock car racer like
before Nascar was a thing
when like stock car racing
was still really kind
of like basically criminal and just
like how she would just like champ
and just like beating all these
men and like her husband was like,
you can't drive that fast
and she was like yes I can,
so I really love that one.
And I don't know who I
would want to interview.
>> Stacey Todd: You've
interviewed a lot of people already.
>> Talya Cooper: I've interviewed
a lot of people already, so.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay
you might be next.
>> Talya Cooper: TBF.
>> Nancy Groce: I've, no I want
to thank all of you for coming.
This has been great.
You're here for another three weeks.
>> Stacey Todd: Yes.
>> Nancy Groce: And I know the
booth isn't really open for tours,
but if people want to see the
booth it's just behind the rear
of the Jefferson Building, we're
in the Jefferson Building now
so if you walk around
they'll be setup.
You're all, you get Tuesdays and.
>> Stacey Todd: Tuesdays and
Thursdays are not recording days.
>> Nancy Groce: And other than that
there's someone there, so again,
thank you all for coming and
thanks StoryCorps for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.